more on the administration perspective
on spending trade the Iran decision and
more Steve Newton is the president's
Treasury secretary mr. secretary thanks
for being here good to see him we
expected the Iran an announcement I
think most people did but the specifics
here you know what are the days that you
have before the next tough round of
sanctions really kick in
well breath the sanctions actually kick
in now but there's what we call a wind
down and maintenance period so we wanted
to be very careful people can't do new
business but people who have existing
business will have a period of time
there's two tranches a 90-day truant for
most things and then 180 day tranche for
energy-related in miscellaneous items
and we wanted to be careful on the
energy markets that we had an orderly
transition away from Iranian oil so
essentially if you get to that point
before this this 180 days is essentially
a time that it could be a renegotiation
well I think we're ready to renegotiate
now I think the president's been very
clear since the campaign and since he
came into office this is a bad deal he's
focused on the term of the deal we don't
want Iran ever to have nuclear weapons
he's focused on the ballistic missiles
and he's focused on the state sponsored
terrorism we've had lots of discussions
with our allies we'll continue to do
that and I in Secretary of Pompeo have
had a lot of discussions and will
continue to do that with our
counterparts so you've heard the
criticism from your opponents
politically who say listen if you tear
up this deal from a previous
administration what's to say to foreign
countries and leaders that any deal done
by why administration really doesn't
stick to the next administration
well Bruntlett let's be clear this
wasn't necessarily a legally binding
deal the previous administration never
took this to Congress to have it passed
and this was just a bad deal the
president has been very clear we don't
want a situation where Iran can have
nuclear weapons now or in the future and
if Iran is sincere and wanting to become
a member of the world community they
should sit down and negotiate reasonable
terms you had European allies filter in
here one after another
French president German Chancellor and
the foreign secretary from Britain who
said this just this week you have to
answer the question what next what if
the Iranians do rush for a nuclear
weapon are we seriously saying that
we're gonna bomb those facilities is
that really a realistic possibility or
do it or do you or do we work with what
we've got and push back on Iran together
so the what next I guess is what most
people are asking well what next is the
sanctions are going in place and the
sanctions worked last time but let me
also be clear and the president didn't
come into office right away and
terminate this he was very careful we've
had discussions he's been very
transparent he made it clear three
months ago
this was the last time he was going to
sign the waivers unless there was a new
deal and you know we'll continue to work
with our allies so what's next is the
sanctions go in place we're gonna cut
off the money to fund Iran's bad
behavior and we're gonna work with our
allies to fix the deal and get a new
deal sure but Iran is talking to the
rest of the European allies to somehow
string something together between them
with the u.s. not at the table in that
negotiation how to how can you one
ensure that the sanctions are tough
enough that you move Iran to action if
the other allies are not buying it what
about these these are very very tough
sanctions so although we have a wind
down period and we are being careful
with the transition I would also say
there are primary sanctions and
secondary sanctions and these will go
after the entire US dollar financial
system here and globally so our
objective is to make sure that we cut
off the money to Iran and these are very
powerful tools that we will enforce so
you're saying Iran will feel it
absolutely and the economy they're not
doing that great anyway it's not doing
very well
their currency has depreciated
substantially and as the president was
very clear he wants to support the
people of Iran there are a lot of people
there they can have a bright future but
their bright future doesn't include
nuclear weapons ballistic missiles and
state-sponsored terrorism
here is the Senate Minority Leader on
this deal you're making it harder to go
after Hezbollah you're making it harder
to go after Iranian activities that are
really dangerous and you're probably
making it harder to come to a North
Korea deal and the foreign president who
weighed in with a statement President
Obama is saying at the time when we are
all rooting for diplomacy with North
Korea to succeed walking away from jcpoa
risks losing a deal that accomplishes
with Iran the very outcome that we are
pursuing with the North Koreans on that
specific point on North Korea do you
think North Korea looks at this and
interprets anything with the kind of
pulling out of the Iran deal right the
president is determined to make sure
Americans are safe if the president
listened to all the professionals he
wouldn't have been tough on North Korea
we put very strong sanctions on North
Korea our maximum pressure campaign is a
major reason why they are negotiating
six months ago people said that the
president was being too tough on North
Korea now he's sitting down and he's
willing to negotiate so the president is
determined whether it's North Korea or
Iran to protect the American people and
the previous deal did not protect the
American people it would have been easy
for him to kick this down the road the
way people did with North Korea the
president not willing to do that
Secretary Pompeo is there tonight in
Pyongyang the president announcing that
is the hope that he comes back with the
three Americans that have been held
hostage there I think I think we all
hope he does and last thing you just
came back from China the the press
write-up of that trip was pretty gloomy
your take on where that trade
negotiation is going I mean it's not
easy stuff but you know these are also
complicated issues and the president has
been very clear going back to the
campaign in an office the trade deficit
is too big that China companies have the
ability to do business here our
companies don't have the same reciprocal
treatment now the good news is since
Mara laga when President Trump and
President Xi first spoke we agreed the
common objective was reduced the trade
deficit and make it reciprocal we
haven't made enough progress in the last
year we went over there I think our
delegation was very clear and going
through these issues we came back we
briefed to the president he's very
supportive of our position and I look
forward to the vice premier coming here
and continuing our negotiations the
president is determined that we will
have a more level in balanced fair and
free and reciprocal trading relationship
and that's our objective so you're
looking forward to round two I am indeed
mr. secretary we appreciate your time
good to see you thanks a lot